Anger and rejection on the streets of Madrid
for a potential amnesty for exiled Catalan separatists.
Six years ago,
an illegal independence referendum
saw some Catalan leaders flee the country.
Carlos preached amon
the most prominent. Now,
over two months since Spain's July general elections,
the country still doesn't have a government.
And forming one could hang on this one decision.
This protest is also a rally in cry ahead
on attempt by conservative leader
Alberto Nunez Veichole
to become Spain's new prime minister.
The problem is that his People's Party
didn't win enough seats in Congress,
despite their uneasy alliance with far right party box.
Acting Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez
has the only realistic chance of winning a new mandate
with a broad leftist coalition.
But he needs the support of the hardline Catalan
June Sparty.
The price is the pardon of its leader
Frij Damont
and his colleagues.
Sanchez opponents
say he is negotiating with fugitives and traitors.
We have a mad man in power right now.
He's neurotic and narcissistic.
Look up the definition in any psychology book
and see how it matches his behaviour.
He lies and manipulates the public.
Poochdomon has to face the law.
That's what justice is about.
To be responsible for his actions
like any other citizen.
We're all accountable for our own actions.
Catalan independence remains
the most divisive issue in Spanish politics
and the government has
defended its conciliatory approach.
They have already pardoned nine Catalan separatist.
It's false, completely False.
That Catalan independence should be decisive
in Spain's governance.
For decades
it's never had fewer votes than. No,
it's another socialist fallacy.
I've seen some of the things that have been said,
not just by the opposition,
but also in the conservative media.
And we've had five years of apocalyptic prophecies
that have never come to pass.
Should such as decide against the amnesty deal,
then it's likely that neither party
will have enough seats to govern.
That would send the country back to the poles again
early next year
for its six general election in nine years.